a pocos días de viajar a glasgow escocia
para la conferencia climática de la onu
el primer ministro scott morrison
anunció el compromiso de australia en
lograr cero emisiones netas de carbono
para el año 2050 esto significa que para
ese año la cantidad de dióxido de
carbono que australia elimina de la
atmósfera deberá ser igual o superior a
la cantidad que emite esto para que el
país alcance la neutralidad de carbono
esto supone un giro de 180 grados en la
política ecológica de australia pues el
actual gobierno federal durante mucho
tiempo se muestra distante a
comprometerse con esta meta que ya
muchos países habían adquirido para
combatir el cambio climático pues ahora
se ha anunciado un presupuesto de 22 mil
millones de dólares australianos en
tecnología y además la creación de 62
mil puestos de trabajo en zonas
regionales para incentivar las energías
limpias australia va por buen camino
para lograr la meta se espera que para
2030 se haya logrado entre un 30 y un 35
por ciento en la reducción además hay
que decir que en estos momentos uno de
cada cuatro hogares australianos utiliza
energía solar
será presentado entonces por parte de
australia en esta cumbre climática